ihr wisst ja dass ich seit einigen
wochen alle paar tage auf die neue
netflix serie to how to handle reagiere
weil sie davon noch nicht so richtig
mitbekommen habe bei tortur handel geht
es darum dass fünf jungs und fünf mädels
auf einer einsamen insel sind und sie
dürfen nichts mit der donau haben wenn
sie doch etwas miteinander haben geht
etwas von ihren 100.000 dollar preisgeld
runter und während dieser sendung
brechen halt doch voll viele teilnehmer
die regeln und dann hat irgendwie die
person was mit der und dann kuschelt er
mit der un der coach mit dem rum und sie
dann wieder mit ihm und keine ahnung was
auf jeden fall knutsch unter anderem
auch harry mit francesca um das sind
diese beiden hier und nach der show
spoiler kommen die beiden auch zusammen
und das waren sie jetzt die letzten
monate und das habt ihr mir ja auch
zahlreich in die kommentare geschrieben
also diese spoiler konnte ich gar nicht
aus dem weg gehen eigentlich ist auch
kein richtiges spyder
ich meine es ist eine reality-tv-show
auf netflix
ich habe meinen reactions hat auf jeden
fall immer so ein job gemacht von wegen
jauch von chats covern oder irgendwie
keinen bock mehr auf kerzers oder auf
harry oder so ich glaube also werden wir
das gehört doch ich wusste halt
insgeheim dass sie halt eigentlich mit
harry zusammen war deswegen habe ich das
dann auch einfach nur so als ob verpackt
die ganze zeit allerdings
gerade jetzt in der youtube das video
gesehen haben
breakball und damit dieses video auch
zahlreiche meiner instagram die ems
geschickt wurde würde ich sagen schauen
wir uns das jetzt mal gemeinsam an
also das ist francesca autohandel falls
jetzt gedacht hat dass harry sein hat
keiner gedacht und sie wirkt hier in den
ersten paar sekunden schon sehr
aufgelöst und sagt dass es ihr dritter
versuch es das video hier zu filmen sie
jetzt allerdings einen anderen weg
einschlägt um bis zehn leuten also uns
zu erklärt ich habe euch übrigens mal
die deutschen untertitel reingepackt
weil ich weiß dass ihr alle komplette
englisch mieten sollte bald schon wieder
geht 26 sekunden francesca du kannst die
thematik doch claudia ein bisschen clean
are bringen aber wenn du hilfe brauchst
also ich hab immer eine offene tür hier
ich würde allerdings sagen bevor wir uns
das video weiter anschauen wollen wir
einfach mal ein bisschen runter und
shampoo die bewertung sind gut ich
dachte die sind jetzt so fifty fifty so
von wegen rentner zwar dobel nach der
show jetzt kommt alles raus aber krass
also die bewertung habe ich mir auf
jeden fall schlechter vorgestellt
in der beschreibung schreibt die first
lady hat dürfen wir in nord börse
profitierte posting des videoweb rating
300 wischte come across essen incentive
bei eure als herz sagt mir ganz klar ja
es geht gerade so viel ab in der welt
corona virus black lips meter die ganze
geschichte mit anti rassismus iz
sie will nicht dass das jetzt so das
thema schlechthin mit den medien und
entschuldigt sich direkt dafür aber ich
kann verstehen wenn es ihnen natürlich
auf dem herzen liegt und sie das den
leuten natürlich auch mitteilen will
dass sie das natürlich auch jetzt machen
möchte
finde ich sehr sehr nah ist sie auch
noch einen text die beschreibung haut
und in die kommentare
während ihrer kurzen auge bleibt jemand
dass die es direkt hätte beenden sollen
als er über den kurs gelogen hat dabei
irgendwie ne zweiten volk oder so auf
dich auch schon reagiert habe dann habe
ich gesagt dass sie ihn zuerst geküsst
hat und deswegen haben die geld verloren
deswegen macht es aber auch harry also
das kann ich auch verstehen wie gesagt
meine tür steht immer auch hier ist bio
wohlmann don't cry of yourself man also
hier wird gesagt harry ist quasi noch
ein baby wie kannst du denn überhaupt
mit dem zusammensein dieses leidige fame
ghetto hitzfeld also eher lästige die
ganze berühmtheit ihm zu kopf steigen
gerade villingen der harrie boers
messing around you want is also das
herrenzimmer die ganzheit fremdgegangen
erlesen einiges wird hier geschrieben
ich will allerdings sagen wir schauen
erst mal das video als anfragen will die
häufigkeit ja eine kette auf der von
chaska draufsteht
das sind genau die leute die dann auch
als handy hintergrundbild 111 von sich
selbst haben wo sie finden dass sie gut
aussehen
okay das ist irre
das hätte ich jetzt nicht geht
die beiden er so eingeschätzt dass
francesca irgendwann die reißleine zieht
aber harry hat es anscheinend getan also
francesca winter in amerika und harry
irgendwie in england
oder australien ist aber auch egal wo
das ist beides mehrere stunden flug
entfernt von daher kann ich auf jeden
fall irgendwo nachvollziehen dass harry
sagt der kann long distance relationship
nicht mehr weiterführen
[Musik]
also ich weiß nicht ob ich das mit den
orten durcheinandergebracht haben
gekommen dass ich dachte sie kommt aus
aber ist auch komplett egal auf jeden
fall wurden die auf komplett anderen
seite des globus also ist jetzt nicht so
von wegen der eine wunde karlsruhe die
andere wohnt in hamburg
und dann sind sie in die vier stunden im
zug es ist eine relativ weite entfernung
und anscheinend hat harry schluss
gemacht das finde ich krass und
natürlich müssten dies natürlich auch
der der öffentlichkeit zeigen weil diese
beziehung stand ja auch die ganze zeit
in der öffentlichkeit und ist ja auch
durch diese lässig sache die in der
öffentlichkeit ausgestrahlt wurde erst
so groß geworden
die haben ja millionen follower gemacht
auf instagram francesca jetzt glaube ich
fast fünf millionen vorher hatte sie
irgendwie 200.000 oder so also es ist
einfach nur richtig und fair dass sie
das video gemacht und bisher finde ich
das wirklich sehr gelungen vor allem in
kombination mit der beschreibung und so
weiter und so fort
man merkt dass sie das thema wirklich
sehr krass mitnimmt also bisher kann man
wirklich sagen ich hab ich auch unten
die deutsche übersetzung eingeblendet
dann alle leute bei denen
geschäftsmodell overbeck ist
auf den geist ich weiß nicht was ich
dazu sagen soll also harry wollte das
ganze erst gar nicht öffentlich machen
weil es wohl irgendwelche gerüchte gab
ihr umgegangen sind und er wollte diese
das ist jetzt nicht dass sich diese
gerüchte bestätigen
dadurch dass jetzt public im nächsten
jahr wir sind auseinander francesca
konnte es allerdings nicht mehr auf sich
behalten sie dachte allerdings dass die
beiden heiraten also sie hatten
anscheinend unterschiedliche ansichten
und ich glaube generell ein sehr
emotionaler mensch ist das hat man
einerseits betone mitbekommen und auch
jetzt nach anderthalb minuten
ok also es war wohl für sie so dass sie
einfach dachte er dass in der kleinere
streitigkeiten wie man halt in einer
beziehung fest so dass es völlig normal
dass in einer beziehung nicht dauerhaft
alles gut läuft allerdings waren für ihn
halt so viele kleinigkeiten dass es
irgendwann zu viel wurde und er
dementsprechend die reißleine gezogen
hat und gesagt hat er kann das nicht
mehr auch nicht
[Musik]
ich finde sich jetzt so alter mit zombie
die habe ich nicht gerechnet ich habe
dieses video hat realtech in den trends
heute zum ersten mal gesehen weil ich
die letzten beiden tage sehr eingespannt
war das geschäftliche dinge angehen und
vor allem einen umzug nach hamburg haben
wir wieder viele sachen leider
besprechen müssen deswegen ich hab mir
dieses video natürlich
selbstverständlich vor noch nicht
angekommen wie bei keiner reaction dass
er auf seinem kanal
allerdings hätte ich wirklich ein video
erwartet von wegen wir haben einfach
festgestellt nach tour-ende wir
verstehen uns
wir bleiben einfach mal zusammen bei ihm
man hat nicht mehr gepasst business weiß
bei harry geht's weiter bei mir geht es
weiter ich hoffe ihr verfolgt uns
weiterhin und da war sowieso nach
bachelor oder bachelorette sind ja auch
immer noch so viel monat zusammen um
komplett social media den ganzen pusch
mitzunehmen danach selbst jetzt
verstehen wir uns wie ich mir das soll
jeder geht seinen weg und am tag danach
sind alle wieder reggae aber anscheinend
nimmt das ganze francesca wirklich
heftig krass mit und das hätte ich
wirklich überhaupt nicht erwartet
deswegen ich bin wo ich bin gespannt
darauf was harry dazu sagen ob er dazu
vielleicht sogar schon was gesagt hat es
ist ganz schwierig kurze pausen und
meine meinung zu den einzelnen sachen zu
sagen weil sie die ganze zeit nur
nebensätze aneinander schneidet also
überhaupt nichts gegen dich von chefs
kai wirklich ich glaube dieses video
auch nicht mal sehen wird falls doch
francesca ich habe eigentlich gerade der
falsche zeitpunkt um solche dummen jobs
aber sie hat hier halt gerade gesagt ja
für sie war es wirklich so dass sie halt
weiter gehen wollte und weitergehen
wollte sollte es versuchen versuchen
versuchen und harry hat aber gesagt nee
das wird ihm einfach zu viel er hat ja
keinen bock mehr drauf ärger kann das
nicht mehr weil es zu ihnen zu viele
kleinigkeiten waren und da bin ich ganz
ehrlich kann ich beide seiten verstehen
eine beziehung ist ja nicht nur weil die
eine person unbedingt will dass es
weiterhin funktioniert dass die alle
personen aus sagt für mich funktioniert
sie mehr über links dann bleibt mir
zusammen also ich weiß jetzt nicht was
diese gerüchte waren die rom gegangen
sind so tief bin ich jetzt auch nicht in
der ganzen gossip sache da drin und ich
glaube auch noch mal dass die serien
amerika bzw england besteigen einem
englischsprachigen raum noch mal ein 44
krasseren hatte als hier bei uns in
deutschland deswegen ich hab davon gar
nichts mitbekommen ich habe nur
geringfügig davon mitbekommen dass die
beiden überhaupt ein paar waren aber ich
bin auf jeden fall gespannt aber wie sie
auch schon gesagt hat eigentlich so darf
es uns nichts angehen es ist deren
beziehung da die beziehung allerdings so
krassen der öffentlichkeit stand und
auch dadurch resultiert ist dass die
beiden sicher in der serie kennengelernt
haben sind die leute natürlich hungrig
und wollen informationen haben da ich
kann alles verstehen irgendwo
sorry dass ich schon wieder pause aber
es ist halt meine reaktion ob des videos
wegen möchte ja auch meine meinung zu
sagen und ich mein ich habe jetzt nicht
die komplette serie tourtermine geguckt
aber die ersten vier fünf folgen der
mittlerweile auf meinem kanal und ich
bin ganz ehrlich ich finde es krass und
ich bin schon interessiert daran was
vorgefallen war von ceska sagt er ganz
klar es sind einige dinge vorgefallen
die ich einfach in einer beziehung nicht
sehe wo ich mich dann auch nicht in der
beziehung sie und was ich nicht verdient
habe auf der anderen seite räumte
allerdings ein dass sie selbst natürlich
auch nicht perfekt ist so wenn ich halt
alle einmal überlegen turtur händel klar
dass es eine serie eine show eine
reality-tv-show das vielleicht auch
wieder fähig aber einfach nur wegen
einer lüge dann harry direkt abschließen
damit kerl zum whirlpool date und damit
ihm duschen gehen und war es ich habe
beide sind nicht perfekt und es hat
einfach nicht gepasst und sie ist halt
sehr emotional und sie dem zeit rast
jetzt gerade wie süß also sie redet hier
gerade davon dass die beziehung
eigentlich wirklich perfekt war sie
dachte ja man sie kommt noch alle zwei
wochen schön zusammen danach haben die
ganze zeit geschrieben davor die ganze
zeit so oft - markiert die teams
herumgeschickt fotos die ganze zeit
geschrieben so das klingt wirklich so
als wären die wirklich nicht
zusammengewesen von wegen hate eternal
wir nehmen den hype mit und alle wollen
uns zusammen sehen und deswegen machen
was und wir pushen uns auf social media
und danach haben eine krasse reichweite
und werden blogger who
oder vielleicht hat es harry so gesehen
ich weiß nicht aber für francesca was
und einen echten emotional krasses ding
und das sagen ja auch alle in den
kommentaren des harry halt eher so ein
kleines baby noch ist sieht man auch am
altar ist aber der war mit einer der
jüngsten in der show und von stars kalt
einfachen man braucht
ich weiß nicht ob wir gerade die
und mit gelesen habt
dies trieb
gesehen anscheinend ist harry wirklich
irgendwie fremd gegangen über einen
längeren zeitraum oder hatte
neben beziehung noch da wo er herkam ich
habe keine ahnung und ich glaube das ist
ja auch relativ easy zu machen wenn die
halb auf der anderen seite der erde sind
sehr ganz
hier steht auch gerade durch die distanz
fühle ich mich als würde ich genauso
traurig gespielt ich bin gespannt ob
davon harry noch mal eine antwort zu
kommt es ganz stark wie die letzte szene
übersetzt wurde ich liebe euch nicht
mehr genau das hat sie so gesagt wie
also real talk das video ist jetzt
vorbei wir haben uns jetzt die sechs
minuten hier komplett angeschaut und ich
muss wirklich sagen ich will mir dazu
keine meinung bilden weil harry dazu
noch nichts gesagt hat ich weiß ich aber
dass noch tun wird weil für den
jazzkeller auch hier gesagt hat dass
harry erstmal gar nicht veröffentlichen
wollte dass sie nicht mehr zusammen sind
weil noch ein paar sachen angestanden
haben aber von chaska konnte das ganze
einfach nicht mehr von chefs kassen sehr
emotionaler mensch hat sie hier gesagt
und francesca musste dieses video hier
machen und sich entschuldigt sich
nebenbei auch noch in der beschreibung
dafür dass es halt gerade irgendwie in
der prophet ist also unangebracht dass
sich dieses video zu diesem zeitpunkt
gerade raus hat mit all dem was in der
welt gerade los geht und sie will die
aufmerksamkeit nicht auf sich haben aber
sie kann es einfach nicht mehr für sich
behalten
deswegen ich finde das sehr plausibel
was sie sagt ich hab nichts davon
mitbekommen dass harry ihn wie keine
ahnung wie gesagt ich bin da nicht so
drin in der tiefe gossip szene aber es
hört sich auf jeden fall krass an
an der stelle mich das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
das kenne einen daumen hoch unter dem
video am morgen kommt eine neue reaction
von mir auf tour händel online das wird
wahrscheinlich sehr komisch sein weil
francesca und harry sich da ja gerade
wieder näher kommen und wir jetzt aber
wissen die beiden sind auseinander und
haben gerade übelsten streit allerdings
befinden wir uns jetzt auch schon im
auto und wenn ihr noch kein abonnent von
einem kanal sein und das morgige video
nicht verpassen wollt dann klickt man
ganz schnell obenauf smiley darauf ist
kostenlos und ihr verpasst hat das
morgige video nicht und dieser teil der
lubu die beschützen
und hier ist ein anderes video verlinkt
das ist meine letzte tour werden
[Musik]